hey yo show about bootleg Capcom the it
was dot-com in the game you know what it
is dj khaled and look out for my album
july 19-3 the best forever on seen them
get money which well the thing with you
is you got like probably more haters
that I say a good ninety percent of the
game like people hate on you a lot I
mean we know it you know you gotta
always remembers more love than hate I
was I would just say like as far as
people people always try to like what
does Khalid do because it's you know DJ
it's a DJ khaled song what but they
don't know that you're like you know you
are a mogul you you are like a producer
with someone when someone sees us a DJ
khaled song right but you know what they
want to know what what makes it a DJ
khaled i'd say i'm like the hip hop
Berry Gordy I'm like the hip hop Quincy
Jones yeah you know saying on I put
these amazing events together they just
don't happen it just doesn't happen say
hey right it's like hot record here's
i'm on one is we take it over riders i'm
so hood not you know it's getting in the
studio coming up with ideas and actually
you know having relationships with
certain artists and you know just kind
of like oh not going to say like oh shot
a Puff Daddy you know say pump daddy
right somebody you know that that did
stuff like that in all Quincy Jones arm
Swizz Beatz you know saying dr. treasure
you're saying Irv Gotti oh this is named
understanding a few people out there a
little job I'm saying like I'm a
producer I'm a boss a mogul boss era as
you say I do it all you started to
dabble in the in the wrapping a little
bit yeah you know I'm a spit some bars
arm on the remixes okay because I hear
what Revis was that you had all i do is
win yes and welcome to my hood so all
the album are you going to be doing any
rapid on the house on the album I in rap
on the album but I gotta
um i would say crap i would say a DJ
khaled vibe well you know saying it
might be some chance and some just
certain type of additives and a certain
type of energy that I playing you know
if you never been to a DJ khaled so you
need an experienced one because i don't
need none of the wrappers around major
with DJ cabbage you say I'll be even
honest and she's like um you know y'all
have summer jams and all that right
right sir I have you had a summer jam
and names some artists ever be in a
summer job um well depends on who's
popping at this I don't work well this
storm will be headlining you know be one
of the top five headliners and then it'd
be hard to perform after me there okay
air it is not show stopper put it that
way i'ma say that's the type of energy i
bring on stage not got a nice set and of
course you know if i decide to get
behind the turntables you know that's
what i do as well that's what you do dj
khaled that's where i come from so like
i'm saying i do that natural all right
like you said you make things happen man
you really do yeah um you know I haven't
met people I've met people who know you
are about interactions with you that
have said anything negative about you um
I noticed you got Jeezy on the album yep
I know that Jeezy and rose they kind of
had a little it was kind of [__]
jeezy's and two things as of course
you're Rosie's man and you know that
should let your family absolutely um
being like like the man of the people
that you are when that kind of stuff
happens because naturally artists have
problems with each other um before you
when you're in the middle of like a lot
of times I'm sure you stuck in the
middle you know what do you do then well
first of all you're saying um I don't
condone problems right you say that's
what I do you know I represent that love
and it's making great music and them two
guys they don't have no problems okay so
you know I guess this is an exclusive a
you know this all up now yeah they they
don't have problems I guess people in
the streets kind of like I guess no
people just try to make things right now
yeah if you always Bubblegum's yeah but
that's just life that's that's when you
know you ha and that's just part of the
game and
no you know being in the game and being
successful you have to deal with things
like that um but you know they ain't go
no problem saw of soul of every uh I
don't know what to tell you like right
there that's an exclusive awesome oh no
there it is hey what's your favorite
favorite record on the album my favorite
record on the album obviously I'm on one
yes but this other records on that love
sleep when it's gone with Cee Lo Green
game that looks like it's gonna sound
stupid yeah that's crazy especially the
music the music mean danger um you gots
it all on the hook selah on the hook oh
yeah and it's not a regular look either
it's like one of them you is special
yeah that's true I love the jeezy &
ludacris racking oh um it's like a
hostel records from our money you know
getting money on another actually like
the future wreck your to the future with
the young guys acehood big sean Meek
Mill wale vato I like that just for the
streets yeah I'm saying oh you see the
growth of the future I love legendary
legendary is one of my favorites because
you got um Chris Brown neo and Keyshia
Cole alone Trekkie whoo it's it sounds
sexy let ourselves be that's that's
that's actually the record the record is
gonna be very motivational it's one of
them records where I'm probably gonna
win a Grammy off of okay its one of them
big oh just one of them like it's gonna
play non-stop it's one of them smash is
so are you saying right now we will see
you at the Grammys oh yeah we are we
working on that and then of course a
love this marriage a record me Mary fab
and Jadakiss my hair single the reason
why I love this record because if you
love hip-hop yeah and you love on be
right you're gonna really love this
record because it got a UH we flipped
the psk our drums yeah I'm saying and
that same time as the topic is called
ain't over till it's over right and I
ain't going nowhere you're saying I'm
gonna continue making these hits for
myself and for other people you were
saying like you know let's try to be the
biggest mobile in the game you feel me
you